c'est plus que les derniers phone c'est
mes amis c'est thomas n'est pas là il va
pas tarder se battre en repartant
ça fait 35 ans qu'on se connaît il est
en apprendre une fois que tu es puis de
torse
et si on faisait un joli jeu on pourrait
par exemple poser tous notre téléphone
sur la table et tout ce qui arrive ce
soir on regarde tous ensemble et on lit
tout about et toi tu montres on retient
à 20 cents mais moi je veux pas savoir
qui s'en sont pourtant enfin mais c'est
amusant
non c'est pas très amusant non c'est non
allez moi je dois arrêter avec le jeu
des rapports qu'on ajoute rigal
poursuite on a failli se battre
vas-y à leur montre mais si je mange le
match contre le tien
[Musique]
tapez on a un message je veux ton corps
merci qui
je te nique ce jeu stabiliser